I'm down off $902
Like five bucks ha ha
I think the idea of like what money means to me has changed
I passed that milestone of like becoming a millionaire late
late 2017
I think money
Doesn't mean too much to me. I don't think we need as much of it as we think we do
People do find it hard to talk about money because it's so private. It's like talking about underwear.
What is going on everyone it's Ricky with long-planned profit, uh yesterday covered profits at
63-31 today during pre market hours it hit highs of
of $69
My name is Ricky Gutierrez, I'm 23 years old and I live in Gilbert, Arizona
What I do for a living is investing in the stock market. I'm an influencer
I own a series of real estate properties and I run a series of online businesses
Yeah, so I put this year with the different products that we have going on I can probably bring in like 6 to 7 million
My name is Azariah Randall and I'm 21 years old and I live in San Diego, California
What do I do for a living? I primarily deliver food. I signed up for this food delivery app
I can make like easily like a hundred a day
Hope you guys all have an amazing rest of your day continue working hard to continue following your dreams
Let your passion be what drives your success. like always guys Let's make sure that we end the year on a green note
Take it easy team
As in trading, not very good, so I'm down about 1% in big picture like it's not much
It's just because I'm right now invested with about $30,000.
Boom boom boom! What's going on guys? I made a mistake and I covered profits yesterday on you guys and look what I missed out on
We have these here, the R right there. I have my other GTR over there. I own that house, too
my favorite part of the day is working with my private group and
seeing the
Excitement that they give back is probably one of the most rewarding things
My goal is to create a series of applications that are worth like hundreds of millions if not billions of dollars.
I think if I had ten billion dollars in my pocket right now
I think I would still be the same person because I have a stronger relationship with my faith
Matthew 6:21 says wherever your treasure is, the desires of your heart will be also
What is going on everyone? I'm gonna be packaging some orders for techbuds apparel
Yeah, so they went for I think a total of like
twenty four days?
Any time that is that they like ask or need something like I'll be like paying my little sister's tuition for her university
and then anytime that they like running low or something then I can assist but
What's up, Instagram? Yo look it's a good day. We got we got John here
He's following me around all day pretending that my life is interesting.
It might be dirty
*music playing* I love this part. *music*
Uh oh! We got a delivery! we got the text message we're going to the Broken Yolk which is down here on 6th
Got room for two of us in here?
Hi. hahahahaha. Bye.
Hey. Woman: Thank you so much! Azariah: Yeah no problem
Oh my gosh
Like I'm down oh my god actually more than I thought 902 dollars
No because I've been down like 2,000 dollars and it recovers and I make like $3,000 on it. So
So, right now as you can see, we don't have any deliveries. So we're waiting playing the waiting game. It's kind of
It like when you text your crush and then you're waiting for her to text you back, but she never does
Honestly I think I messed up in this position
I'm someone that like I value the dollar so much. like you somebody go to Chipotle and I won't get a drink I
Just became very frugal from a very early age and very aware of
how to try to make money and the stress that it brings on and seeing how it
Acted as a negative catalyst for my parents' relationship
I went to McDonald's and I
overheard that my parents weren't doing as well financially and my cousin was like oh
I want a Big Mac and I want large fries!
I like looked at him and I was like, "no, no get that!" like you know? just because of the extra cost
That's when I really started to
You know, try to buy and sell like Snicker bars or Powerades just to pay for myself
So my parents didn't have to pay me
Well, that one's gonna pay like, nine bucks at Asia Wok, let's go
Yeah, yeah yeah. Two dr. Peppers, seafood delight, house egg rolls and egg flower soup? Ooh. Yeah awesome
This order is hella big!
Waiting round two
When I was growing up we were, we are good financially up until my age like seven, I guess I would say?
That was when my mom was like a single mom to me and my two sisters
We didn't know we were poor or like broke or anything
Cuz my mom did such a good job of hiding it and just like grinding and hustling
But then like growing up I kind of did understand like our financial hardships
Look how much we got paid for that 35 bucks cuz that's like with a fat tip and whatnot. Yeah
This is exciting
She says she's missing an item. Woman on phone: Yes. I'm so sorry. Yes. There's another part of your order. We have it back here
There's three salads, right?
Okay. Thank you
Boom boom boom. How many of you want to turn your passion for cars into profit we are reopening the 30-day flippin rules mentorship challenge
We showed that last time in three days. All you have to do now is swipe up to learn more. I got terrible news
they don't have the tomato and mozzarella panini, but they do have...(voice trails away)
Think it's this building right here. Is this 2230? Woman: Yeah, this is me. Dope! Woman: Thank you! Yeah, no problem
It's been super slow for like an hour
Probably won't get any more orders just because we're downtown and everybody's probably like on their way home already right now
Yeah, we'll just call it a day
Do you think that money defines people? Or do you think it defines you?
I think I think in today's role
money definitely does have a...a
Huge form of credibility
I believe money can define you if you let it. I don't believe it defines me personally, at all
I've had
Like 27 cents in my bank account and also have had like $3,000 in my checking account
It was just like ready to ball out, you know, and I was the same exact person
Interviewer: Does money buy happiness? no, that's when these are on someone who does not buy happiness one. That's a quick one
Are you happy? I'd say I know definitely I'm very happy with
There's no reason not to be happy right? with where it is that I am but there's definitely moments that um
Feels like kind of like, I don't know, just like empty
I think money can buy happiness
But it can only buy either temporary happiness or things that make you happy
I Am. I'm very happy. It's it's weird. I'm like smiling answering that and like I like struggle with depression and stuff
So it's weird, but it's like, like I'm very freakin happy
You always come through with nice-ass cars. I don't understand how. They're nice.
I appreciate it man. What's your name again? Kyle. Kyle? Nice to meetcha. I'm Ricki
yeah with everything I'd say probably around about 11,000. Yeah
You know continue working hard to continue follow dreams let your passion be what drives you and your success
And like always let's make sure that we win the year on every note
Let's go
Hey make some noise for me if you broke
All right, y'all hesitated you're all getting robbed by the end of this set tonight today
We made six while we were out in like almost five hours
Which is like 12 bucks an hour, I?
Think minimum wage is like 11.50
I would like to be making more money and I'm trying to figure out ways to do that
People have lately been telling me I'm funny I found that out recently
So that's part of the reason I just started doing stand-up comedy. I can definitely make people laugh
We've got the light I know right he may have they but write the check right the check
So all my friends that graduated high school just graduated college and I'm like dang
They broke they like a hundred twenty thousand in debt. I'm just like two thousand in debt. He's moving
So who won we did we'd all read books. You feel me like